the graph of y is equal to absolute
value of X is reflected across the
x-axis and then scaled vertically by a
factor of seven what is the equation of
the new graph so pause the video and see
if you can figure that out
alright let's work through it together
now now you might not need to draw it
visually but I will just so that we can
all together visualize what is going on
let's say that's my x-axis and that is
my y-axis y equals the absolute value of
x so for non-negative values of X Y is
going to be equal to X absolute value
zero zero absolute value one is one
absolute value of 2 is 2 so it's going
to look like this it's just going to
have a slope of 1 and then for negative
values when you take the absolute value
you're going to take the opposite you're
going to get the positive so it's going
to look like this let me see if I can
draw that a little bit cleaner this is a
hand-drawn sketch so bear with me but
hopefully this is familiar you've seen
the graph of y is equal to absolute
value of x before now think about the
different transformations so first they
say is reflected across the x-axis so
for example if I have some x value right
over here before I would take the
absolute value of X and I would end up
there but now we want to reflect across
the x-axis so we want to essentially get
the negative of that value associated
with that corresponding X and so for
example this X before we would get the
absolute value of x but now we want to
flip across the x-axis and we want to
get the negative of it so in general
what we are doing is we are getting the
negative of the absolute value of x in
general if you're flipping over the
x-axis you're getting the negative Y or
your multiple you're scaling the
expression or the function by a negative
so this is going to be y is equal to the
negative of the absolute value of X once
again whatever absolute value of x was
giving you before for a given X we now
want to get the negative of it we now
want to get the negative of it so that's
what reflecting across
the x-axis does force but then they say
scaled vertically by a factor of seven
and the way I view that is if you're
scaling it vertically by a factor of
seven whatever y-value you got for given
X you now want to get seven times the
y-value seven times the Y value for a
given X and so if you think about that
algebraically well if I want seven times
the Y value I'd have to multiply this
thing by seven so I would get Y is equal
to negative seven times the absolute
value of x and that's essentially what
they're asking what is the equation of
the new graph and so that's what it
would be the negative flips us over the
x-axis and then the seven scales
vertically by a factor of seven but just
to understand what this would look like
well you multiply zero times seven it
doesn't change anything but whatever X
this is this was equal to negative X but
now we're going to get two negative
seven X so let's see two three four five
six seven so put something around that
so our graph is now going to look is now
going to look like this it's going to be
stretched along the vertical axis if we
were scaling vertically by something
that had an absolute value less than one
then it would make the graph less tall
it would make it look it would make it
look wider let me make it at least look
a little bit more symmetric so it's
going to look something something like
that but the key issue and the reason
why I'm drawing it so you can see that
it looks like it's being scaled
vertically it's being stretched in the
vertical direction by a factor of seven
and the way we do that algebraically is
we multiply by seven and the negative
years what flipped us over the x-axis